à cannes les cinéphiles on retrouve
aujourd'hui avec plaisir le cinéaste
italien nanni moretti qui avait été
retiré en 91 parce qu'il était gravement
malade qui est aujourd'hui guérie et qui
redécouvre la vie caméra au poing avec
talent reportage d'une école cornu
langlois et didier d'aran il a tellement
eu peur de quitter cette vie il a décidé
de profiter vite de tous de redécouvrir
des joies seul et même si parmi incluant
des obligations pour une escapade avec
nous dans les ruelles du vieux sud y est
qu'ils ont un peu la même allure et sa
balade à rome en vespa
c'est le premier volet de la trilogie de
ce journal intime il emmène sur la tombe
de pasolini comme dans les îles
éoliennes fini l'observation corrosif de
la société italienne des agressions sur
la télévision
ils se contentent d'accumuler des
absurdités avec la caméra ils servent
est-il en réalité le cinéaste revori
petit film l'individu moretti avec
jubilation et salue ce même de sa
maladie plutôt des médecins dont le ton
et le style assez grande les médecins
sont un peu à l'opposé on ton indigné de
certaines émissions de télévision
j'ai voulu raconter mon histoire parce
que je pense avoir trouvé un ton juste à
complaisant avec moi même à ça dit
qu'avec des spectateurs et pas morbide
avec la manif anti conventionnel dans
lequel ils avancent à visage découvert
et c'est ce qui fait sa force